everyone today's video is brought to you
by viral academy viral academy is a
step-by-step course on how you can turn
your passions to a career on YouTube
kind of like what you did but in a more
formal setting so you guys know we
weren't always youtubers and Joe was
working a logistics company I was a
tutor and we really wanted to do comedy
on YouTube and we kinda had to do it the
hard way to figure it all out and we
were very unmotivated and not passionate
at our jobs and when we finally became
youtubers were able to put comedy out
there any guys see all these new
channels now we're much more fulfilled
and viral Academy can teach you how to
do these things in a step-by-step
process one student who went through
this process is Laurie from the icing
artist so she used to work this crappy
job preparing furniture didn't really
like it but now she does what she loves
on YouTube which is baking cakes so if
you want to try YouTube as a potential
career go down to the description box
below and click the link but the course
is not cheap it's made for people who
are serious about starting their YouTube
careers also it's gonna take some hard
work to become successful you're not
gonna become a successful youtuber
overnight but when you do become
successful you're gonna wake up every
morning happy and passionate about what
you do like us well actually I don't
wake up happy and passionate every
morning but I'm here at work doing
YouTube to see if it's right for you go
ahead click the link in the description
box below put in your email to get a
free lesson there's nothing to lose and
you get to have a free lesson so if
you've ever even had the slightest
interest on being on YouTube or you just
want to know how people like me and Joe
are able to make a career on YouTube I
would sign up for this free lesson so
you could better understand how to make
viral videos thank you now it's time for
a viral video
three two one action
hey guys I'll go back to up the record
where we talk about whatever we want and
it's the end house cats we got Nikki
back and they're steep and we're back
from the holidays happy music my dad mer
he looks no I just my lighter
get that I didn't even pick out the
stuff you did I mean I shopped for it he
chose to wear this today a new year's
resolution to look is different but it's
a only did it cuz my wife's gonna be on
just share a little bit share a little
bit why did you put on a dress shirt for
once in your life he said it was private
and want to hear it no he he puts on
dress shirts but then it's like the same
shirt for one month that's correct
and then the next shirt it's like
because dude was liking last month was
the pineapple yeah I realize I realize
that was happening because I wanted to
like increase his wardrobe last year so
I bought you know a couple pieces for
him to wear and I realized that you kept
wearing the same one over and over and
over and over again because he doesn't
hang his stuff up and he doesn't like he
doesn't know how to iron and he doesn't
know how to stop talking about me like
I'm not here so he just wears the one
that doesn't have wrinkles and so that
was the pineapple shirt it looks like
I've got you bunch of shirts why don't
you wear them because they're wrinkled
well what I gonna know he doesn't iron
anyway you should have a few more is
easy I have a steamer Oh still doesn't
use that you know if you've got for
Steve those subscription boxes where
they just send you like a new item or
two a month let's show you just slowly
at your wardrobe we want shower now
unless a sponsor is she tried to hook me
up with one but the lady was annoying
and she wouldn't leave me alone oh yeah
I kept hounding him I'm like why don't
you sign up for this yet why Jennifer
yeah that lady was annoying just put
your size and they'll send your shoes
and socks everything it's too much work
Bart listening man ears you're not
listening with like regular these
immense she lost me when she said what's
your hat size I was like a mouth not
wearing no [ __ ] hats am I wearing a
Bart hat or whatever that
why don't you want to work yeah you
ready hey what does that happen odd
shapes head change all her hats it's a
it's a track to read all about it the
actors going to World War two it's a
nickel apiece that's what that is The
Paperboy hand did pay point you buy you
a cowboy hat looks good in hats for the
sake I could do it I couldn't I can do
cowboy hat oh okay my man no I'm taking
my present makes people look like pretty
cool in a cowboy hat I think you said
you got to get those cowboy shirts to
where there's signs right here like I'll
wear bolo ties with pearl buttons how
are you look like rubbers we all looked
our stereotype what's a happy Laguna
stereotype you got to invent it I think
they're just they're so America they
like love like like just all-american
stuff did an American flag dress yep
this seeing everything and just like
[ __ ] Frank Sinatra's can we also say
only our races catchphrases like I say
finger lickin good thing that your rhyme
II know that racist catchphrases
that's my races catchphrase yeah AFC
slogan summaries listen looking good
thank Cassie finger looking good yes say
it's all volunteer thank you very much
thank you
welcome back hmm yeah Europe you
absconded for like a good month right
man I think I was gone longer than
Vietnam this time did you see country no
so i until a crazy thing is I want it to
be different from Vietnam where I don't
really have an agenda and I'm just gonna
figure out where the [ __ ] I'm gonna go
but I knew for sure that I was gonna
come back from the Netherlands oh okay
my buddy um there's not make your way
there somehow yeah yeah cuz I got a
one-way ticket to London and then my one
week I mean my my return ticket was from
Amsterdam so I knew of the dates I just
didn't know what I was gonna do in
between house it was an FINA Amsterdam
was pretty nuts I was only there for one
night though we were in Amsterdam today
we
literally just stoned and walking around
do you remember anything I do but it was
crazy because it seemed like the same
thing cuz you know how the block is
mm-hmm and you know what's funny is when
I when you responded to me I was high as
[ __ ] yeah cuz I did a story and then
Gio was like I know where that sex show
is or whatever on the canal but all of
the wait though the way the blocks are
shaped you get lost [ __ ] easily
especially at night yeah yeah there's so
many bikes yeah and then you know how we
figured out how we where we were it was
the girls yeah they're all different
no they were like oh yeah because
there's like a black girl area by the
church just just for a black lady
shoulders like women and there's like
blonde so these companies want
transaction in it by genres or pornhub
there's like the list of categories and
like yeah just like organized like a
blonds house yeah then more recon with
all the hoes into those away excuse me
do you guys know where the black girl no
yes really
cuz there's an actual look if you want
like a Indian chick that has like the
silks the stomach sticking out with the
red dot you can find out like anything
you want why any so true tenors holding
ladies to pause can or stomach be in but
she's right up not maybe not maybe not
okay anything yeah there's grandmas
there's like super skinny girls big
girls and this is all for [ __ ] to be
clear yes what do you think for cleaning
houses what are you like you see them on
the window and then it's [ __ ]
intimidating though because like it's
all out in the open and then the girls
are just like [ __ ] come here come
here and then you know when you're
stoned you just stand there and you just
stare and you don't know how long you're
standing there for I feel like I was
standing there for like five minutes
with my friend it's like what do you
want to do I don't know it's kind of
scary I know the cool ask them I don't
know and then the whole time the girls
are standing there
dating though you know what you know
what it is
the girls like I'm getting me an Asian
male hooker and then you're standing the
Asian male hooker spots don't none of
your mother hey come on let's go come on
[ __ ] boy yeah I got 50 yeah they'll be
like whole tour groups and just fat
nothing
yeah I guess families cuz it's like
Mary's family yeah there's there's just
like whole groups of like there's
grandma and and you know the grandson
and whatever they're just like pointy
and like tourist attraction yeah and
while at the same time there's guys that
are just walking up and I just walk you
straight in and coming in and out and
I'm just like [ __ ] I don't know I was it
was too weird man I was like should I
try this try not I was it was like
playing jump rope I was like [ __ ] I
don't know man I don't know what to do
here Jared didn't you nah it was kind of
too scary because I was way too paranoid
and stuff didn't [ __ ] answer portable
I'm disappointed yeah buddy bucks yeah
no I didn't I did talk to them those
gorgeous woman you were seeing yeah he
was gonna he was thinking about it he
was like really close oh yeah but I
heard someone stopped him a liar second
I was like what are we playing this on
camera right now I'm like no way man
that was good thought you know you can
catch me I was trying to clean it up for
you cuz I wasn't sure if you wanted on
camera or not be a good friend I thought
no you called me a no way man I walked
through there I walked through there
with my with my future wife we were
there and we were there the first year
we were together we fought in every
single country in your own home I
actually banned and Stephen in Amsterdam
restaurant because I was so [ __ ] now
you got to go back and create new
memories yeah yeah cuz when I tell you
the first year of us together was like
the worst it was the worst like we
almost broke up in Germany it was hollow
mantak insane
I know we're like touring Europe like
all these countries or just fighting it
well that's the word we baked in every
country - we did we banged in every
country really fun we were hot well
there's balance there I'm cold
I just fought yeah what are they were
they like stupid fights yeah oh yeah
terrible they were all like surface
level there were there's deeper issues
but like we're fighting on about this
issue because this one wasn't resolved
yeah and then Steve was jet lag the
whole [ __ ] time so he was just like
really grumpy and I was pissed because
like we only had a few days in each
country because it was like a tour that
we were doing and I wanted to see as
much as possible and I wanted to take
pictures and I was like excited to be
there and he was just grumpiest pissed
off dude he wouldn't want him every time
I asked him to take a picture he was
like oh [ __ ] can't eat me man we're
never coming here again because neither
of us like pay for like cold places like
we've always do crop achill vacations
when we go on vacation so like we're
never when are we coming here again
we're never coming here again I just
want a few pictures and he's just the
grumpiest [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't think
it was Corden oh yeah I always called
this [ __ ] and I started the trip in
Denmark she wasn't even there yet
because she had talked about commercial
yeah she came and met me in an in London
which is much nicer by then yeah she met
me when I was already [ __ ] six days
of piste and I was so excited to be in
London with my boyfriend of less than a
year I was so excited and he was just a
[ __ ] [ __ ] we still [ __ ] in every
country we did while you were angry
angry makeup sex is kind of the best
thing where did you go during the winter
because yeah it's a depressing man yeah
like that's what I to realise that
Hollywood [ __ ] with my mind yeah I love
it during the winter he didn't have a
coat cos dumbass him thought like cold
mentally
so I could do the hoodie it's a
different level of call to different
have a call so I thought people west
coast are [ __ ] oh no dude this is
like below rocks I didn't bring like the
idiot socks
oh I was pretty proud I was like better
than the locals of like therapy oh man
they're so different and I'm so happy
that I was able to check out both
Eastern Europe
well not Eastern but I guess check is
right in the border and then there's
Central Europe right right there and
Amsterdam
I mean Austria and then that's more like
German culture and then you saw like you
know of course the UK is closer to
America in a way and then all the way up
to like Amsterdam but like there's so
many different I guess versions of like
white people in the cities and to the
Sweden no I was gonna go to Scandinavia
but I ended up not because everyone was
like it's so [ __ ] dark there why
would you go there now that's what I
heard everywhere we went they were like
you should come back in the springtime
why are you here now cuz we were there
early March and like just before
springtime was about to having like why
did you come now there's a lot of go -
what - from this summer yeah
the spring the flowers start to blossom
why did you see hothouse girls there in
Sweden uh yeah well everyone's tall and
blond he fit right in
he looked like he was from there but
people came up to me and said the
language and I was like oh
everyone's you're super nice there's a
metal there was a metal bar where
everyone's like you know gods and like
punk rock like Mohawks and it was with
the bartenders were like hello sweet
there yeah I'm so you went to all these
countries hottest women go hardest with
oh my god ranking ranked the countries I
I thought to not do die I can't even
explain the [ __ ] hot level out there
is totally different so many flavors of
hot yeah and they're actually burned by
all this heat huh are you purple is heat
yeah it's [ __ ] facial hair
[ __ ] burned out my know like it's um
okay so I so for so I think being in
America to like the we don't really know
the difference of white like from
Eastern European to like British wide to
like all that right and when I was there
I could really tell until toward the end
of the trip I'm like okay I can see like
this person's more Central Europe or
Eastern or like Russian or like whatever
right yeah yeah and dude they're all
like different kinds of hot it's almost
like saying like who's hotter like
Mexican girls or Cuban girls like
they're still [ __ ] hot but they're
like a different kind of latina right
and I think the cool thing though is the
culture there is a lot more friendlier I
think than the States because it's
easier out there to just talk to women
and hang out with them like just cold
for me at least then I think in LA or
maybe like go anywhere else that's true
it but I mean cuz I was born and raised
here right honest you know someone that
knows someone you're somebody or you're
part of a click or a group that's
popular or whatever I think it's just a
different kind of scene overall and out
I think people here are a little bit
more like paranoid and jaded of like
threatening things but out there yeah
there's just easier in people or more
doubt I just talk and have conversation
there are climbers I don't think there's
social climbers a lot of quite a lot of
them make good money like the women
they're educated they make good money
they're not looking for like like you
know a husband immediately or they're
just looking for love or just the
connection or they're just looking to
[ __ ] real quick I heard in New York was
like that
that might be a myth but like a lot of
New Yorkers I know came around they're
like yeah in New York it's so easy to
talk to people in LA people don't want
to talk to you
maybe well New Yorkers pretty directly I
heard that New Yorkers are meaner though
no they're not they're before lunch
[ __ ] yourself okay like if you have
something I think you were problem
someone they just tell you the instead
of like being fake-nice and then talking
yeah that's kind of cool but
passive-aggressive yeah yeah but I don't
know yeah cuz Ellie is so different
right you got your Hollywood LA and then
the bad perception of LA where people
come in as transplants and he try to be
actors the majority of LA yeah and well
the majority of what people think
because they go back home and they get a
bad impression of LA but us as locals
the majority of LA we know la différence
but you guys are all like outskirts of
LA but that's the real LA not Hollywood
yeah that's really Santa Monica in that
little corner of Italy that's the that's
the industry LA its industry yeah yeah
that's why Christmas Day you could drive
around LA anywhere you get anywhere in
15 minutes because everyone's a
transplant they all won yeah like we
travel every time every year and then
this year we actually stayed here and
I'm glad we can actually get from here
to here in ten minutes what the problem
is you get there and they're closed yeah
because all the transplants work there
anywhere 15 minutes but they're all
[ __ ] day no I also observed too that
there's a lot more mixed relationships
there then I've seen anywhere else in
the world whether it's London or you
know Vienna or whatever mixed with what
Nami like racial oh yeah you it's it's
it's it's very common like you see a ton
of different and it's like different
mixtures I think cuz the ethnic groups
out there just different in general so
you'll see like more like the ground
Nepal or Middle East wall in Cambodia
now yeah yes white people everywhere I
saw them like I'm like oh girl with red
kills with the guy with the black coat
there is a [ __ ] ton of white people
though yeah that's what I know that you
seen that you could literally country
hop
within hours like you could go to so
many different countries on by train
because like here we have Canada and
Mexico they're both really far away from
each other like you really have to plan
out a travel trip to go to either
country but they're you could just take
a day train to a different country
different countries and you could see
every
during sheep and the language changes
and everything that's crazy and changes
it's nuts but they all know English like
I feel like most of them know at least
two languages yeah cuz I felt so dumb
I'm like oh my god I'm such a foreigner
I could don't know other languages I'd
like I'm so ignorant and stupid but then
they all knew English and I was like oh
my god I was so thankful and then I felt
bad for every time a foreigner came here
and didn't know English but we treat him
like [ __ ] I know cuz we don't help if
they don't I can go fish learn the
language you [ __ ] it forward like we're
[ __ ] a lot of them know like at
least two yeah yeah yeah it's pretty
crazy and it's taught in schools from a
young age like here like you take an
elective by the time you're in high
school and you only need to take two
years and you don't remember any of it
except the UK though I didn't know many
people out there that were multilingual
well you don't really need to because
their first language is English yes I
think it's mainly English speakers that
don't need to know yeah languages but if
you go into Central Europe or Eastern or
whatever they know like multiple like
they know their hometown language and
then they'll know like German and don't
know like you know English or whatever
systems work really well yeah and they
know how to drive in the wrong side of
the road did you know that well most of
them actually drive the cars that we do
with the the roads that like our system
it's just it's just the UK their money
is all [ __ ] up though I had a guy like
carry a treasure chest to like every day
because the euros and all that but the
thing is they just used cars like it
looked to a lady like I was like like I
had a pile of socks I was like yeah
which one how do I pay for this I don't
know what I'm in there their flights are
hella cheap in-between because that's
the main reason why I did it that way
cuz it was so easy to just book
something I saw a flight from I think
was Vienna to London for like $26
one-way ticket yeah I'd be losing money
on that come on uh a lot of it is
government subsidized that's why they
can do it that way yeah and did you know
there's a train from [ __ ] London to
Paris under though I've heard of it yeah
cuz I'll staying next to the Perry
Potter station it's like Kings Cross or
whatever and it was like the glasses
came did you see this the one
half thing did you see the [ __ ] did
you jump through cuz they added a oh no
they painted it naughty watch they're
ready knee of the books I watched the
movies but I forgot like 90% well I
don't know the number so I would always
be i would just look for the half things
only something 3/4 something like that I
didn't look I didn't treasure hunt the
the station unfortunately I just saw
that and I was like that's [ __ ] crazy
then you did in travel no ID 9 in 3/4
did you see Peter Pan statue the Peter
Pan stuff you drink butter beer I didn't
do many honestly I do much know where
they did it yeah I did it did you do
then what tourists do you take the
[ __ ] picture in the [ __ ] the
telephone booth
he showed me a Austrian hotdog that lip
balm did you take oh did you take a
picture next to the to the cat to
another all you did was eat one giant
fish and chip big deal did you talk to
you to them ago hey you [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] you're gonna move yeah I
didn't do it yeah it was really [ __ ]
weather too so it was like rainy went
dead of winter I didn't get to do all
the tourist stuff sighs [ __ ] market
oh yes that was the [ __ ] dope [ __ ]
right there Christmas market what's that
one I went to this hole they have a huge
thing called winter wonderland it was
like a big-ass [ __ ] festival it's
like imagine a carnival Plus show Plus
whenever you just drink there and chill
yeah where's that it's in London moment
yeah but I mean all across Europe though
they have these Christmas markets all in
like it's [ __ ] dope handcraft
their food from like all over Europe
gold wine have you had that cold wine I
make that every year I make the best
mulled wine Wow
good alright I liked it we wanted to
throw a Christmas party this year but we
like we're vacationing and and then we
got sick yeah everyone I was sick too
yeah there's just so much [ __ ] that
went down I don't know I didn't do any
tourist [ __ ] it was crazy what [ __ ]
went down hard Steve man thank up for
you Matt good for you
[Music]
[Music]